welcome to this video playing hockey ha
or HGH not sure what this stands for and
we played the Sicilian here let's see
with 92 let's open up he cannot really
take 25 looks rather embarrassing uh-huh
Wow lots isn't this isn't this okay
where do you go I just returned and d3r
93 why not it's interesting at least not
sure if it is good but it's interesting
if it takes I intended to 95 threatening
93 and that f3 checkmate could be could
get hairy for what
hmm Oh curious why what is he doing okay
so what now just take just take it
if I play five just draw for on you and
sake and he takes a nap lacy for isn't
this trapped yeah the night is trapped
but if I he probably will go to d5 yeah
but then I can take a plane 94 I'm not
sure if if I was really a move that I'd
like to play okay it's really wicked in
d5 a play gt5 or is this completely
ridiculous g5 problem it looks a really
funky g5 I come on let's play crazy game
here 93 I play C 4 nights 524 their
heaters needs to go here and now I
thought them is six actually
so take now Oh with what you need to
take with the Queen's along hmm I
thought Queen takes Knight deform okay
okay so I need to make something of my
g5 stuff play age five but the crazy
position this is the Gandalf don't try
this at home game night you five again
moving this night really yeah probably
to have some point behind all this see
intending d4 yeah maybe Knight f6 yeah
anyway but what can you do
take care pruning Bishop c5 yeah this
also that's also just G hive hanging but
also night b5 coming well with the wacky
position maybe you counter to check or
early fall yeah I was really asking for
it getting such a such a wacky position
and therefore I don't don't understand
this is some a problem just Knight to c6
now right
yeah just just a piece of now what do we
had game
yeah I don't want to give up a pawn here
i get b to pack anyway need to get
material of the board now here Bishop c6
I want to go
get rid of the bishops night f2 is quite
a threat here
at least I hope it's a thread I'd also
Roxy to as a possible idea yeah I
probably wasn't very bad shape earlier
this was a bit too creative probably
with the chief five yeah that's all I
didn't come on now in wuxi one on the
night wolf and intending yep this one
try to get the pony
check
check
yeah probably i'm trying for stalemate
yeah or something check check as long as
the check it's not a stalemate and this
isn't the same rate as well check I'm
morning Jake yeah this was probably
lucky let's check this crazy opening
again it's really strange okay I can
play a normal movie end and be okay i
mean i just want to move slow with t4
but this is at least interesting and now
probably just taking him just take on c2
it's good from a position of point of
view but i was tempted at this crazy
move who came back here I really I
really overlooked night see to as simple
as this movie is I didn't consider it
yeah h5 is probably the best and those
this special circumstances yeah and this
I don't know you have 93 the conference
play 93 and it's actually good young
black 93 m justice just a concrete good
movie needs to take cannot really keep
the the night there and then i have the
Queen on d3 very strongly positioned
okay if this is nonsense then yeah this
is much
white 9 p-5 is good for instance but
this is already okay for black yeah this
just gives away a piece I probably just
blend up that it's just just losing
losing the house yeah what did we add
game but sometimes you need to play some
crazy moves as well 11 moves was just
one piece develop the rest is pawn moves
yeah don't try this at home but he looks
the same night all the time night let's
see 3 p-1 f45 III 92 funny alright i
hope you enjoyed this crazy game